for the past couple lectures we've been
talking about Ross theorem and we showed
so we saw a proof of glass theorem using
Fourier analytic methods and we saw
basically the same proof but in two
different settings all right so two
lectures ago we saw a proof in F 3 to
the M and basically the same strategy
but with a bit more work we were able to
show Ross theorem with roughly
comparable bounds in over the integers
today I want to show you a very
different kind of proof of Ross theorem
in the finite field setting so first let
me remind you the parent that we saw
last time for roster in F 3 to the M
gave an upper bound on the maximum
number of elements in the 3 P free set
that were of the form 3 to the N over N
and so this proof up wasn't too bad
right so we did it in one lecture and
then with a lot more work and people
willing to try very very hard to improve
this and there was a paper that got it
just a little bit more and this was a
lot of work and this was something that
people thought was very exciting at the
time and then just a few years ago there
was a major breakthrough a very
surprising breakthrough where you know
at this point it wasn't even clear
whether 3 should be the right base for
this exponent and that was a big open
problem and then it was a big
breakthrough where the following bound
was proved that it was exponentially
less than the previous bound so this is
the one that I want to talk about in the
first part of today's lecture and so
this development came first the
histories have been interesting so crude
leaven Park uploaded the people to the
archive May 5th 2016 where they showed
not exactly this theorem but in a
slightly different setting in this group
so in Z mod 4 instead of Z mod 3
and and this was already quite exciting
getting exponential improvement in this
setting but it wasn't exactly obvious
how to use their method to get f3 but
that was done about a week later so
elenberg and hash wit they managed to
improve use this technique modify the
crude left part technique to the f2 to
the air setting which is the one that
that we've been interested in so there's
a small difference between these two
namely this group has elements of water
too which makes things a bit easier to
do it here with so this is the crude
left Park method is often called in
literature and we'll see that it's a
very ingenious use of this so-called
linear algebraic method in common it
works in this case the polynomial method
and it works specifically in the finite
field vector space setting so what we're
talking about this part of the lecture
does not translate whatsoever it is with
nobody knows how to translate this
technique to the integer setting okay so
how does it work the presentation I'm
going to give follows not the original
paper which is quite nice to read by the
way it's only about four pages long it's
a pleasant to read but there's a
slightly even nicer formulation on
Carrick house block and that's the one
that I'm presenting so the idea is that
if you have a subset of F 3 to the n
that is 383 and such a set also has a
name cap set which is also used in
literature for in this specific setting
where you have no three points on the
line in this case then we have the
following identity so here Delta is the
Dirac Delta let me write that down in a
second
so the delta of a is the Dirac Delta is
either one if x equals to a and zero if
X does not equal to it so this is simply
rewriting the fact that XYZ from a
through a P if and only if their sum is
equal to zero and because you're 383 the
only three ApS are the trivial ones
recorded on the right hand side so this
is simply a recording of the statement
that a is 3 P 3 and the idea now is that
you have this expression up there and I
want to show that if a is very very
large then I could get a contradiction
by considering some notion of rank so we
will show that the left hand side is in
some sense wrong rank I haven't told you
what rank means yet but the left-hand
side somewhat no rank and the right-hand
side is a high rank object so what has
ranked me so recall from linear algebra
so the classical notion of rank
correspond to two variable functions so
you should think of f as a matrix over
an arbitrary field F so such a function
or a corresponding matrix is called rank
1 if it is nonzero and it can be written
in the following form f of XY is f of X
G Y for some functions that are one
variable each so in matrix language so
this is a column vector times a row
vector
so that's the meaning of rank one and to
say that something is of high rank of a
specific rank rather the rank of F is
defined to be the minimum number of rank
one functions needed to write F as a sum
or linear combination so this is rank 1
and if you add up our rank when
functions then you get something that's
most rank R so that's the basic
definition of rank from linear algebra
for three variable functions you can
come up with other notions of rank okay
so what about three variable functions
so what how do we define the rank of
such a function so you might have seen
such objects as generalizations of
matrices called tensors and tensors have
already a natural notion of rank and
this is called tensor rank just like how
here F is we say rank one if it's
decomposable like that we say F has
tensor rank one if the three variable
function is decomposable as a product of
one variable functions as a potential
rank it turns out okay so this is an
important notion which is actually quite
mysterious there's a lot of important
problems that boil down to us not really
understanding what tensor rank how it
behaves and it turns out this is not the
right notion to use for our problem so
we're going to use a different notion of
rank here rank one is decomposing this
three variable function into a product
of three one variable functions but
instead I can define a different notion
we say that f has sliced rank one so
this is definition that's introduced in
the context of this problem although
it's also quite a natural definition if
it has
one of the following forms so I can
write it as a product of a one variable
function and a two variable function
it's one variable and the remaining two
variables but this definition should
also be symmetric in the variables so
the other combinations are okay as well
so this is the definition of a rank one
function a slice rank one and also non
zero if it's nonzero and can be written
in one of these forms and just like
earlier we define the slice rank
of F to be the minimum number of slice
rank one functions right same as before
that you need to write I say some I can
decompose this F into a sum of slice
rank one functions what's the most
efficient way to do so so that's the
definition of slice rank and you see you
can come up with this definition for any
number of variables where slice rank 1
means decompose into two functions where
one function takes one variable and the
other function takes all the remaining
variables and then for two variables
slice rank and rank correspond to the
same notion okay any questions so far
all right so let's look at the function
on the right so think of it as a matrix
or tensor so what is it well it's kind
of like a diagonal matrix so that's what
it is it's a diagonal matrix so what is
the rank of a diagonal matrix in this
case diagonal function well you know
from linear algebra that if you have a
matrix then the rank of a diagonal
matrix is the number of nonzero entries
so something similar is true for slice
rank although it's less obvious
you will require a proof so if I have
this three variable function defined by
the following formula so in other words
it's a diagonal function where the
entries on the diagonals are the CAS
okay so what is the rank of this
function that's sort of slice rank in
the matrix case it will be the number of
nonzero entries it's exactly the same
here none number of nonzero diagonal
entries that turns out to be the slice
rank let's see a proof so we go back to
the definition of slice rank and we see
that one of the directions is easy okay
so this less than or equal to greater
than you caught you okay so which one is
easy
see the right hand side is a some of our
of a this menu rank one functions so
this direction is okay so this direction
is clear I'm just looking at the
definition I can write F explicitly as
that many rank one slice prank one
functions okay so the tricky part is
greater than or equal to and for the
greater than or equal to let's assume
that all the Bagnall entries are nonzero
okay so why can we do this if it's not
nonzero I claim that we can remove this
element from a okay if the CA is not
zero then I remove a from the set and
doing so cannot increase the rack know a
probably the rank might go down if you
get rid of an entry right because if you
add an entry even though the function
doesn't change on the original set if
you increase your set maybe you have
more space maybe you have more
flexibility to work with especially if
you remove an element so the rank cannot
go up
No so suppose the slice rank of F is
strictly less than the size of a so all
piece CAS are nonzero so suppose for
contradiction that there's some
different way to write function f that
uses fewer terms so what would such a
sum look like so I would be able to
write this function f in a different way
like that and then now I look at these
other types of functions using different
combinations of the variables
okay so suppose there were a different
way to write this function f that uses
fewer terms
okay so I assume uses exactly the size
of a minus 1 terms and always putting 0
functions if you like ok so now I claim
that there exists a function H on the
set a whose support so the support is a
number of entries that give nonzero
values the support of f is bigger than M
such that the following sum is 0
okay so I claim that okay so we can find
a function f H such that think of it as
in the kernel of some of these F so this
is a linear algebraic statement okay yes
sir it's just H it's a single function H
such that this equation is true for all
X's
you are right so okay so what do I want
to say here
so we want to find a function H such
that the support of H is at least
okay so right so what do we want to say
I want to say that yeah so your right
side this is not what I want to say and
instead it's something
okay so let's accept so here we have
some number of functions guys who have
some number of functions and for each a
I have four each
I'm sure know so I do want to show no
there's no induction because I'm in
three variables and I want to get rid of
so the point is okay so let's see where
we're going thankfully and then we'll
figure out what happened up there
so we want to consider okay so I would
like to eventually consider the
following some so I wouldn't consider
this sum which comes from okay so you
look at so let's look at this f of X Y Z
ok so f being that sum
so take that F up there and let me
consider basically taking the inner
product of this function viewed as a
function in Z okay so consider this in a
product and if I so what I want to say
is not this so what I want to say is if
I look at in the product of H with so
take one of these halves okay take one
of these apps and look at the look at
the bilinear form relating H and F so
that this sum vanishes for all I between
n plus 1 and the size of a minus 1 okay
so this role I want to vanish when being
taken bilinear form with h so that makes
sense now okay
all right so the fact that such a non
zero H exists simply as a matter of
counting parameters it's a linear
algebraic statement you have some number
of freedoms you have some number of
constraints so it's a set of such H ok
satisfying all of these constraints so
there are this many constraints well
each one of them could cut you down to
one dimension s but the set of such H is
a linear subspace dimension bigger than
M yes I have eight dimensions and I have
these many constraints so the set of
such H is there are lots of
possibilities and furthermore it is also
true that and this is a linear algebraic
statement that every subspace of
dimension M plus 1 has a vector whose
support has size at least n plus 1 ok
I'll leave this as a linear algebraic
exercise it's not entirely obvious but
it is true now you put these two things
together you find that there is some
vector so I think of the coordinates of
the vectors has index by the set a there
is some vector whose support is large
enough okay
yeah so we prove the claim let's go back
to this this lemma about this diagonal
function having high rank take H from
the claim ok so let's take H from the
claim then let's consider this sum over
here on one hand what the sum is is you
know you can do the sum on the on the
right hand side we see that it's like
multiplying a diagonal matrix by a
vector so what you get following the
formula on the right hand side it's the
following we write this part sum over a
C sub a H of a delta sub a X Delta sub a
of Y just looking at a formula from the
right hand side on the other hand if you
had a decomposition up there doing this
sum and noting the claim we see that the
third row is gone so what you would have
is sum over this this
like this so you would have a some
values of the form F 1 of X and G tilde
1 of Y where G tilde is basically the
inner product of G 1 as a function of Z
with H X G and then also so there exist
some functions G which come from G
thought that would come from the cheese
up there such that this is true ok but
now we're in the world of two variable
functions so left hand left and right
hand side are two variable functions and
for two variable functions you
understand what is the rank of a
diagonal function so the left hand side
has more than M diagonal entries because
H has support so the number of diagonal
entries is just the support of H whereas
the right hand side has rank so now
linear algebraic matrix rank at most M
and that's a contradiction okay so we
can show a similar statement for
arbitrary number of variables by
generalizing this proof and using
induction on the number of variables but
we only need three variables for now any
questions it's just a recap what we
proved is the generalization of the
statement that a diagonal matrix has
rank equal to the number of nonzero
diagonal entries but the same fact is
true for these three variable functions
with respect to slice rank so this is
intuitively obvious but the execution is
slightly tricky all right so now we have
this statement here let's proceed to
analyze this function which comes from
so this relationship here coming from a
set a that is 383 so suppose now I'm in
so many so everything so far
works generally with any eight but now
let me think about specifically
functions finite field vector space F 3
to the N function taking value F 3 and
this function is defined to be the
left-hand side of that equation over
there so the claim is that
okay so the left-hand-side claim that
this function has low rank so we claim
that a slice rank of this function is
that most three M where m is the sum
essentially this multinomial coefficient
okay we'll analyze this number in a
second but this number is supposed to be
small all right so we want to show that
this function here has small rank so
let's rewrite this function in a form
explicitly as a sum of products by
expanding this function after writing it
in a slightly different form so in F 3
and the three variable in characteristic
so in F 3 you have this equation you can
check that it's true for X equal to 0 1
or 2 so take that and plug it in over
here so we find so now XYZ are in F 6
p.m. so we find that applying this guy
here coordinate wise
so you have this product great now let's
pretend we're expanding everything this
is a polynomial in three and variables 3
n variables its degree as qm so if we
expand we get a bunch of monomials and
the monomials they all have the
following form so the axis which whose
exponents I call I the Y's whose
exponents I call J and disease whose
exponents I call okay where so get a sum
of monomials that where all of these IJ
is in case are either 0 1 or 2
all right so I get this big sum of
monomials and I want to show that it is
possible to write this sum as a small
number of functions that can be written
as a product where one of the factors
only involves one of XYZ so what we can
do is to group them ok so group these
monomials
by the so for example okay so I'm going
to group these monomials by using the
following observation so by pigeonhole
at least one-half of the exponents of X
or the exponents of Y or the exponents
of Z at least one of these guys is at
most two n over three so I group these
monomials by one of X Y Z that has a
smallest exponent so the contributions
to the rank or the slice rank from
monomials with the degree of X being at
most 2 and over 3 well I can write such
contributions in the form like that
where this f of X is a monomial and the
G is a sum of whatever that could come
up this is a sum but this this is a
monomial so the number of such terms ok
so the number of such terms is the
number of monomials corresponding to
choices of ice that sum to 2 n over 3 an
individualised coming from 0
one or two and that number is precisely
M so M counts the number of choices of
zero one tooth there are n of them and
the sums of the Isis at most 2 n over 3
okay so these are contributions coming
from
Gnomeo square the degree of X is at most
2 and over 3 and similarly with degree
of y being 2 and over 3 and also the
degree of Z being at most 2 n over 3 but
so all the monomials can be grouped in
one of these three groups and I count
the contribution to the to the slice
rank okay the question is do we have a
good idea as to how sharp this bound
this that's a really good question
I don't know so that finishes the proof
of this lemma ok so now we have this
lemma I can compare ok so we have these
two lemmas one of them tells me the rank
of the right hand side which is a let's
compare ranks the slice rank
so the left hand side we know it has at
most this quantity and the right hand
side is equal to 8 so we automatically
find this bound because now we want to
know how big this number M is
so there's actually this is a fairly
standard prom to solve to estimate the
growth of this function M so let me show
you how to do it and this is basically
the universal methods notice that I can
if I look at this number here where if
okay so now X is some real number
between 0 & 1 then I claim the following
is true and this is because if you
expand the right hand side and count
your monomials so just keep track of
which monomials occur and there n of
them where you can lower bound by this
quantity here so this is related to
things in probability theory on large
deviations for the premier theorem but
but that's that's what you can do so
this is true for every value of x so you
pick one that gives you the best pound
so M is at most
of this quantity here okay and and you
know to show you any banner I just have
to plug in some value so if I plug in
for example X being 0.6 I already get a
bound which is the one that claimed okay
and and it turns out you know this this
step here is not lossy that's an
basically up to one plus not align the
exponent this is the correct bound and
that follows from general results in
large deviation theory and not finish
the proof alternatively you can also
estimate am using Sterling's formula its
but this I think is cleaner great any
questions
okay so why is this step true so if you
expand the right hand side you see that
the right hand side is upper bounded by
all these ABC s in same as over here X
to the B plus 2c right and because how
many terms and also there's a binomial
coefficient so basically I'm doing the
multinomial expansion except I hustled
everything which is not part of the
index and because B plus 2c is at most
two n over three I get M times X to the
alright you know I want you convey a
sense of mystique about this proof this
is this is a really cool proof okay so
because you're seeing lecture maybe when
we buy very quickly but you know when
this proof came out people were very
shocked they didn't expect that this
palm would be tackled would be solved
using a method that is so unexpected and
this is part of this power of the
algebraic method in combinatorics where
we often end up with these short
surprising proofs that take very long
time to find but they turn out to be
very short so this is very short this
was basically a four-page paper but when
they work they work beautifully they
work like magic but it's hard to predict
when they work and also these methods
are somewhat fragile so unlike the
Fourier analytic methods that we saw
last time where that method you know
it's very analytic work works in one
situation you can play with the massager
work make it work in a different
situation
here you know we're using something very
implicit very
special about these many variables and
if you try to tweak the problem just a
little bit the method seems to break
down all right so in particular it is
open how to extend this method to other
settings it's not very clear what the
results should be right so it's open to
extend it to for example for a piece I
said we do not know if the maximum size
of 483 subset of F 5 to the N is less
than some constant 4.99 to D okay so
that's that's very much open by the way
all of this 3 AP stuff right now I've
only done it in F 3 but works for 3 AP
in any finite field it also is open to
extend it to corners ok so you can
define a notion of corners so previously
we saw a corners integer grid but
replace integer by some other group so
you can define a notion of corner step
so not clear how to extend this method
the corners and also is there some way
to extend you know some ideas from this
method to the integers there's
completely fails right so this methods
not clear at all how you might have a
work in a setting where you don't have
this high dimensionality I mean the
result will be different because the
integers we know that there's no power
saving but maybe you can get some other
bounds any questions
okay great let's take a break so in the
first part of today's lecture I showed
you a proof of roster F 3 to the end
that gave you a much better bound and
what we did with for a second part I
want to show you another proof ok so yet
another proof of Ross in F 2 to the N
and this time giving you much worse
bound of course I do this for a reason
ok so we'll give you us and the new
result so we'll give you some more
information about 3/8 piece and F 3 to
the N but the more important reason is
that you know I in this course I tried
to make some connections between graph
theory and one kind and additive common
networks on the other hand and so far
we've seen some analogies in the proof
of similarities graph regularity lemma
versus the proof the Fourier analytic
proof of Rosse theorem there was this
common thing of structure versus pseudo
randomness but the actual execution of
the proofs are somewhat different
because on one hand in regularity lemma
you have energy increment you have
partitioning and energy increment and on
the other hand with Roth you have
density increment or you're not
partitioning you're zooming in take a
set find some structure zoom in find
some structure zoom in you've kept
density increment so it's similar but
differently executed so today I mean
this second half I want to show you how
to do a different proof of Rosse theorem
that is much more closely related to the
regularity proof right so that has this
energy increment element to it and I
show you this proof because it also
gives you a stronger consequence and
namely we'll get that there is also not
just three atps but three a piece with
popular difference so here's the result
that we'll see today
so it's proved by penguin now for every
epsilon there exists some and not
such that every a being subset of F 3 to
the N worth density
alpha there exists some nonzero Y such
that the number of three a piece with
common difference Y okay so so let's
think about what's going on here so if I
just give you a set a and ask you how
many three ApS are there and compared to
what you get from random random meaning
if a were random set of the same density
so questions can the number of three a
piece be less than the random count okay
and the answer is yes so for example you
could have in the integers you can have
aberrant type a construction there's no
three a piece so certainly it has fewer
three piece than random and you can do
similar things here but what greens
theorem says is that there exists on
popular common difference so this is a
popular common difference such that the
number of three a piece in a with this
common difference is at least as much as
what you should expect in a random
setting up to a minus epsilon so this is
this is a theorem okay so let me say the
intuition again says that given an
arbitrary set a provided a space
dimensions large enough there exists
some popular common difference where
popular means that the number of three a
piece with that common difference is at
least roughly as men
yes random in particular this proofs
roth's theorem right because you have at
least sound 3 a piece but it tells you
more it tells you there there's some
common difference that has lots of three
APs
even though on average if you just take
an average if you take a random wire
this is false any questions about the
statement all right
so green developed an arithmetic analog
of similarities graph regularity in
order to prove this theorem
ok so starting with similarities graph
regularity lemma he found a way to
import that technique into the earth
metric setting in F 3 to the M ok so I
want to show you how roughly how this is
done and just like in some rarities
graph regularity lemma there the world
on the voidable bounce which are of
tower type the same thing is true in the
arithmetic setting so greens proof shows
that the theorem is true worth and not
being something like tower in a tower of
two's the height of the tower is
polynomial in 1 over Epsilon okay so
just like in regularity lemma for graphs
so this was recently improved in a paper
by fox and fan but just a couple years
ago where and this is the this is a
proof that I'll show you today where you
can take and not to be slightly better
but still a tower but powernow height
log in 1 over Epsilon really really big
tower to just slightly less big Tower
but more importantly it turns out so
they also showed that this is tight you
cannot do better
there exists constructions there exists
sets a from which you this theorem is
false if you replace the big ol by less
than some very small constant so many
applications are the regularity lemma
you know the first proof may be using
regularity in the difficult gives you a
very poor bound but subsequently there
were other proofs better proofs that
give you non power tight bounds but this
is the first application that we've seen
where it turns out the regularity lemma
gives you the correct bound so it's
really you need a tower type I mean we
know the regularity lemma itself means
tower type bounds but turns out this
application also needs tower type bounds
that's quite interesting
so here the use of regularity is really
necessary in this quantitative sense ok
so let's see the proof so let me first
prove a slightly technical lemma about
bounded increments so this is
corresponds to the statement that if you
have energy increments you cannot
increase too many times but in a
slightly different form so suppose you
have numbers alpha and epsilon bigger
than zero and if you have this sequence
of ACE between zero and one and such
that a naught is at least alpha then
there exists some K at most log base 2
of 1 over epsilon such that 2 a sub K
minus a sub K plus 1 is at least
alpha cubed minus Epsilon okay so don't
worry about this form will see shortly
why we want something like that but the
proof itself is very straightforward
because otherwise so you start with a
knot now then if this is not true for K
equals to 0 then a 1 is at least to a
naught minus epsilon cube plus epsilon
naught is at least of a cube so if
otherwise you have some lower bound down
alpha 1 so which is at least of a Q plus
Epsilon and likewise you have some lower
bound of alpha 2 you have some lower
bound down alpha 2 and this lower bound
is plus 2 Epsilon okay so you keep
iterating you see the next thing is for
epsilon and so on so if you get to more
than this many iterations you go more
than one okay it's bigger than 1 if K
yes ceiling of log base 2 of 1 over
Epsilon and that will be a contradiction
to the hypothesis ok so this is a small
variation on this fact that you cannot
increment too many times each time you
go up by bit
whereas we save a little bit because the
number of iterations is now logarithmic
because you double in epsilon each time
what
if I give you a function f f3 to the M
and you it's a subspace so this notation
means subspace let me write f sub u to
be the function obtained by averaging f
on each you Cosette so you have some
subspace you partition your space into
translate of that subspace and you
replace the value of F on each co set by
its average on that Co set so this is
similar to what we did with graphics
you're stepping
so you're averaging each block so now
let me prove something which is kind of
like an arithmetic regularity lemma and
I mean this statement will be will be
new to you but it should look similar to
some of the statements we've seen before
in the course and the statement is that
for every epsilon there exists some M
which is a function of Epsilon and in
fact it will be bounded in terms of
power of height and most waterlog with
making one over epsilon such that for
every function f on f 3 to the n that
our value is bounded between 0 and 1
there exist subspaces W and you
we're the co dimension of W is at most M
so you should think of this as the
course partition in the fine partition
in the partition regularity lemma and
the co dimension is corresponds to the
number of pieces right so three ways to
call dimension is the number of cosets
so you have bound in many parts and have
two partitions and what I would like is
that the number okay so if I I want F to
be pseudo-random after doing this
partitioning so to speak
and this corresponds to the statement
that if I look at F minus FW then the
maximum Fourier coefficient yes quite
small we're quite small means that most
epsilon over the size of you complement
size of U perp and also there is this
other condition which tells you that the
l-3 norms between F sub U and F sub W
are related in this way so we haven't
seen this before in fact specifically
this inequality is very ad hoc to the
application of popular difference in
three APs
but we have seen something similar where
this relationship is replaced by
something that accounts for the
difference between our two norms so if
you go back to your notes when we
discussed regularity lemma in a more
analytic fashion we have that and you
should think of this you know when we
discussed strong regularity lemma this
definition here is roughly corresponds
to the definition in the fine partition
versus the coarse partition the edge
densities are roughly the similar when
you do the further partitioning we're
not changing densities up by very much
okay so that's arithmetic regularity
lemma and once you have the statement I
mean I think the hardest part is writing
down this statement once you have the
statement I mean the proof is office
kind of this follow your nose approach
where you first define the sequence of
epsilon epsilon naught is 1 epsilon
sub-k plus 1 and okay so don't worry
about this for now you will see in a
second why these numbers are chosen let
me write R sub K to be the set of ours
so there will be characters such that
before a coefficient and R is at least
epsilon sub K okay so the ours are
supposed to identify how we're going to
do the partitioning now the size of this
R is bounded so we claim that the size
of R is at most one over epsilon sub K
squared and that's because there is this
possible identity which tells you that
the l2 sum of the Fourier coefficients
is equal to the l2 of the function which
is at most 1 so the number of Fourier
coefficients that exceed a certain
quantity cannot be too many
okay so let you now be the subspace
defined by taking the orthogonal
complement of these R's and let's note
that if we take alpha sub K to be the if
we take alpha sub K to be the l3 norm
cube or the function derived from
averaging F along the use and then
looking at the third moment of these
densities so these alphas we can apply
the increment lemma initially to deduce
that there exists okay so in particular
this number here is at least alpha cubed
by convexity so by the previous lemma
there exists some K no more than on the
order of 1 over a log 1 over epsilon
such that 2 alpha sub K minus alpha sub
K plus 1 is at least the density of F
cubed minus Epsilon okay so this alpha
is supposed to be the density of F
all right so we find this K and we have
this bound over here from satisfying
that inequality so this is a density
increment argument the energy increment
argument doing the energy in chrome
argument basically the same argument as
the one that we did when we discussed
graph regularity lemma
but now presented in a slightly
different form in the different water of
logic but it's the same argument and
what we would like to show is that you
also have this pseudo randomness
condition about having small Fourier
coefficients so what's happening here
was the Fourier coefficients you know
how is the Fourier coefficient of an
average death related to the original f
so that's something we want to
understand up there and that's something
that's not hard to analyze because if
you have a function U or W 1 then the
Fourier coefficients of this averaged
version it's very much related to the
original function it turns out that if
you take an R which is in the orthogonal
complement then the Fourier coefficient
doesn't change and if you are not in the
orthogonal complement and before your
coefficient gets zeroed out
okay so that's that's something that's
not too hard to check no urge you to
think about it
so with that in mind let's go back to
verifying this over here so what we have
now is that the so this quantity which
measures largest for your coefficient
the difference between F and u sub k
plus 1 is at most and what u sub k plus
1 is doing is we're looking at possible
large Fourier coefficients and we are
getting rid of them right so we're
zeroing out these large for your
coefficients so that the remaining for
your coefficients are all quite small
but we chose our R so that if so this
big R so that if your little ARS not in
a big R then the Fourier coefficient
must be small that's how we chose the
big R so so we have this bound over here
and by the definition of the epsilon we
have that bound so we're combining with
this estimate upper bound estimate on
the size of our sub K ok so point being
so now take W to be u sub K + 1 + u to
be u sub K and then we have everything
that we want
great questions why is the co dimension
of W is small so what is the co
dimension of W so we won't know that the
co dimension of W is bounded right so
the co dimension of W is hoping the co
dimension of any of this u sub case is
at most three raised to the number of
ours that produce it and the size of our
is bounded so if we pick M to that so
that uniformly bounds the size of our
then we have a bound on the cult
dimension okay so that's that's
important right so we need to know that
we call dimension is small otherwise you
know if you do have the ban on all
dimensions you can just take the zero
subspace trivially everything is true
you have a regularity lemma and what
comes with the regularity lemma is a
counting lemma so let me write down the
county mama and I'll skip the proof so
the county level tells you that if you
have F and G both functions on F 3 p.m.
and you it's a subspace then ok so let
me define so the quantity that I'm
interested in is so I'm interested in
understanding 3 a piece where the common
difference is in a particular subspace
okay so we claim that the three AP count
of F with common difference restricted
to the subspace you so it's similar
between F and G if F and G are close to
each other in for you
not quite because okay so something like
this we saw earlier in a proof of Ross
theorem if we don't restrict the common
difference turns out if you restrict the
common difference you lose a little bit
okay so you lose a factor which is
basically the size of the complement of
you so I won't prove that but now let me
go on to the punchline so if we start
with again F function in your space
taking values between 0 & 1 and I have
subspaces U and W I claim that P if I
look at f average through W and I
consider 3 AP counts with common
difference restricted to you then this
quantity here is lower bounded by this
difference between L 3 norms
okay so I claim this is true so this is
just some inequality right there's some
inequality and you know so I for all the
things that I did back in high school
doing math competitions I think the one
skill which I think I find most helpful
now is being able to do inequalities and
you know I thought I would never see the
three variable inequalities again but
when I saw this one so you know Fox and
famine when they first showed me a
somewhat different proof of an approach
that didn't go through this specific
inequality I told them hey you know
there's this thing I remember from high
school it's called sure sin equality and
I thought I would never see it again
after high school but apparently it's
still useful so okay so what shirt's
inequality says this is one of those
three variable inequalities that you
would know if you did Math Olympiad okay
so it's inequality between non-negative
actually it's true for real numbers as
well but let's say it's non-negative
real numbers so that's your sanity so if
you look at the left hand side
the left-hand side is it can be written
as a sum in the following way I mean it
can be written in the following way
so it's expectation over XYZ that are
three APs
in the same you Cosette there's I'm
counting three a piece with common
difference restricted to you so common
three a piece in the same new Cosette
and I am looking at the product of F sub
W evaluated on this three AP so what I
would like to do now is apply shirts
inequality to a B and C being these
three numbers the point is you have this
ABC on the left and then everything on
the right involves only a subset of ABC
and they simplify so if I do this then I
lower bound this quantity by twice the
expectation of x and y in same coset
same you co set F sub W of x squared and
F sub W of what maybe I've took two
other things but they're all symmetric
with respect to each other and minus the
term that corresponds to this sum of
cubes like that okay so this is a
consequence of shirts inequality applied
with ABC like this
but now you see over here I can analyze
this expression even further because if
I let Y vary within the same you Cosette
then over here averages out to you
cosets right so U is bigger than W so
what we have is so what we have over
here is that it is at least twice of F F
okay
half of you f w squared fu minus
expectation of F W squared F W cubed
and I can use complexity F sub W to cat
which is what we're looking for
I'm learning through a little bit
quicker because we're running out of
time but all of these steps are fairly
simple once you observe the first thing
you can do is search in equality and
we're almost there it's a work we're
almost done we're almost done so from
that lemma up there
I claim now that for every epsilon there
exists some M which is power log in one
over epsilon such that if
f is a function on f3 to the end
taking values between 0 and 1 then there
exists a subspace you of codimension at
most M such that the 3p count 3 AP
density with common difference
restricted to you is at least the random
bound minus epsilon okay why is this
true well we put everything together
choose U and W send regularity lemma and
by counting lemma we have that the 3 AP
density of F so it is at least so we're
using counting lemma over here it has at
least three AP density of F sub W view-
a small error which we could control so
this step is counting and now we apply
the inequality up there
and finally we chose our U and W in the
regularity lemma so that this difference
here is controlled so it is controlled
by the random bound minus Epsilon
and that's it so you change epsilon to
for epsilon but you change it back and
that's it so we have the statement that
you have this subspace of bounded
codimension
where you have this popular difference
result it doesn't quite guarantee you a
single common difference because well
you don't really want it to be the case
where u is just a single point because I
want a nonzero common difference but if
u is large enough and it's large enough
I found that codimension
so that the size of U is large enough so
then there exists some nouns your own
common difference you pick some nonzero
element of you on average it should work
out just fine so I'll leave that to you
one more thing I want to mention is that
all of this machinery involving
regularity in Fourier as were things
we've done before carries over to other
settings general abelian groups and also
the integers and you may ask well we
have this for 380s what about longer
arithmetic progressions in the integers
it turns out it is also true you know
that green statement in the integers if
you replace 3 AP by 4 AP that's a term
of green and how involving higher-order
quadratic analysis of quadratic for your
analysis however and rather surprisingly
for AP it's okay but five AP and longer
it is false the corresponding statement
about popular differences for five AP in
integers is false there are counter
examples so it's really a statement
about three pieces for a piece and
there's some magic cancellations that
happen for a piece that make it true
okay okay so that's all for today